I want to ask you about getting started
in this business cuz you are you are
quite a talented fellow oh really are
and and then I think about well what's
it like in the beginning did you when
you were sort of just trying to pull it
all together and get those early
auditions yeah did you ever have to or
get the chance to work with a big
celebrity a big star well right when I
was starting I had an audition for a
movie called Wild Bill and it was I had
an audition with like the casting
director it was just like my third
audition ever isn't like 1995 or
something and by some fluke I ended up
moving along and getting up to audition
with Jeff Bridges and I had never
auditioned really before and all of a
sudden that was in a room with this
giant star and it was so scary I really
gonna be terrified it was Tara just
getting started yeah I was like I had
like a lollipop and was holding a
balloon I was like but I remember
sitting in the in the waiting room for
that and it was a Western so I didn't
know like should I wear should I wear
like Western gear to this audition what
is going on I don't know I I just wasn't
sure what you were supposed to do and on
an audition I put on like a flannel
shirt or something but didn't know if
that was enough and just as I was
wondering that and I swear to God
Matt Damon walks in for the audition for
the audition and I swear to god it's
been a long time but I swear what I
remember is he was wearing Spurs sat
down oh it's over
well how did the actual audition go it
went horribly I I remember Jeff Bridges
was there and they were I guess they
were close to shooting cuz he was in
full cowboy garber knew was he was
starting to talk what you know he's a
whack talking like that about I want to
say 15 years ago and never and he's
ducks who he is
every character if he plays an English
Lord yeah exactly
he's that guy so he was doing that and
so that was weird and scary and then
Richard zanuck was there was just like
Hollywood heavyweights Walter Hill was
the director and I remember I I did I
tried the audition once and Walter Hill
just kind of came up to me and he said
listen do you want to try that again and
I was like yes please thank you so be
answered if they say that the answer is
probably always yes yeah and I tried it
again who's way worse and so I just I
left and did not get that wrong did they
how do they let you know that it's over
and that age we don't they just excuse
you from the room and then you never
hear from them again right I've had
relationships like that yeah